-Thank you so much
for being here, pal.
-Thanks for having me.
-Not only am I talking
to the great actor Steve Zahn,
but I'm also talking to one
of "People's" Sexiest Men Alive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoa.
Look at you!
That's what I'm talking about.
-I think it was obviously
a horrible mistake.
-No, wait, look how sexy
you are in this.
-Yeah, but...
[ Cheering ]
-Yeah.
-I -- No, honestly, when they
said, "You want to do this?"
and I said -- I laughed.
-Yeah.
-And I said no.
And then, like, every woman
in my life went,
"What, are you crazy?"
-Yeah, you have to.
-"You have to do it."
And I was like,
Alright, okay, I'll do it.
-Are you comfortable
doing these photoshoots?
-No, that's the point.
-Yeah.
-It's one thing if they were
like, "Congratulations,"
but then you have
to actually go and do it
-And be sexy.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-And you can't possibly.
-You can't help yourself.
-No, I went in and...
In the moment,
I was very nervous,
and I looked like
I was taking a picture
for the yearbook.
You know, like --
-Yeah, exactly.
-But my photographer --
this is great.
My photographer gave me two tips
on how to look sexy.
-Oh, wow.
-Okay, one is,
if you don't know
what to do with your hands,
you look like you're just like,
scratch a little bit.
-Uh-huh.
-But don't just plant it.
It's not like, you know...
-Oh, really scratch?
-Yeah,
you don't have poison ivy,
but it's like, you know.
-But it's something.
-And then he said,
"Your look is,
'Did I leave
the oven on at home?'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Not bad. That's it.
[ Laughter ]
That's not bad.
Hey, buddy, I have to say,
really,
and I would say this
to you off-camera as well,
but what you did, your
performance in "White Lotus"
was unbelievable.
[ Applause ]
-Thank you.
-It is a master class in acting.
You were so in the zone --
I was gonna say
you're in the Zahn,
but I wouldn't do that.
That's corny.
I didn't want to do that
because really,
I'm going to say that
someone said that
we're in a Zahn-issance.
And I said, that doesn't
even make sense.
I think we're in a...
-Yeah, no, that's weird.
-Renai-zahn-ce.
-A Zahn-issance.
-But I didn't write this, so...
-Yeah, but if somebody says
it's a Zahn-issance,
then it's like --
I wasn't in a coma, you know?
Like, I've been here.
-Oh, yeah.
-I've been doing stuff.
-Yeah, Zahn-issance almost
sounds like a Toyota-thon.
-Well,
it's like you disappeared.
-Oh. Oh, really?
-You know.
-Yeah,
but you've never gone away.
-No. No, I've been here.
-Yeah.
You crushed this thing.
What was it like?
Where did you film?
It was during the pandemic.
Were you in Hawaii?
-Yeah, we were in Hawaii.
So, you know, like everybody,
we were all in our houses
and I hadn't worked
in eight months,
and then I got
a call to do this,
and it's Mike White,
and it's an amazing script.
-Was the script amazing
when you got it?
-It was incredible.
-I know he's an amazing writer.
-Yeah, it was great.
-I know it was done so quickly
that you just don't
see television almost this --
-We did 6 hours in 2 1/2 months.
-That's what I'm saying.
It's fantastic.
-And we were at the
Four Seasons Resort in Hawaii.
-It was closed.
-Closed.
I was gonna say,
there's no humans there, yeah?
-Yeah, so we were in a bubble.
-Wow.
Everybody in the whole show
was phenomenal.
-It was an amazing cast.
-And then I got to...
We got to see more of you
than most people
get to see of anyone.
-Well, that was fake junk
on a fake me.
-It wasn't even you?
-No, because Mike was like,
"Hey, you have to approve
the prosthetic."
[ Laughter ]
-Or prosthetics.
-Yeah.
-Right? It was more than one.
-Yeah. And he was like,
"Is this cool?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, I don't care."
-But you had to look at it
and approve it?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. I did.
-You go,
"That's kind of like mine."
-And then I was like,
"Do I have to put that over?
That doesn't make any sense."
Like...
And he was like,
"Well, you don't have to.
We can put it on somebody else."
I was like, "How long
is it going to take?"
He said,
"Like two and a half hours."
I said,
"No, I'll go to the beach."
-Yeah, "I'm in Hawaii.
I've got to put this thing on?"
-So it wasn't me.
-So it wasn't even you.
Wait, sorry. So, good.
-How absurd is that?
-It's like,
the guy was naked
and then they put a naked thing
on him to look like...
-Like he was naked.
-Yeah,
our society is so crazy now.
-Yeah, it's wild.
But you just crushed it, buddy,
so congrats on that.
You got just amazing reviews
and well-deserved.
Just awesome, awesome,
awesome job.
-Thanks.
[ Applause ]
-But let's talk holidays.
Let's talk about it
"8-Bit Christmas."
I want to talk about this.
I love holiday movies.
-Awesome.
-That's my jam.
I love video games.
-Well, then this movie
is right down your alley.
-Yeah.
-So my son wants a Nintendo.
It's like, 1988, '87.
He wants a Nintendo.
-Everyone did.
-Right.
8-bit, you know?
So it's, by today's standards,
not very good.
-Yeah.
-And we don't know
about it, as parents.
I play his dad.
-Yeah.
-But it's told --
Neil Patrick Harris is
my son, older,
telling his daughter his story
of how he wanted
a Nintendo for Christmas.
-Are you in that generation,
where you grew up with Nintendo?
-Yeah.
-What games?
What are you playing?
-My wife and I,
we were poor actors in New York.
-Yeah.
-True story.
And we went out, and because
we were so pissed at being poor,
we went out and we got sushi
and bought a Nintendo 64.
I swear to God.
-You go, "Enough is enough!
I don't care!"
-And we live in Hoboken
and played "Zelda."
"Legend of Zelda."
-That's my favorite.
That's my favorite.
-"GoldenEye."
-"GoldenEye" is another classic.
What else did I love?
I had the wrestling one.
I think was called "Wrestling."
-Yeah.
-This was back in the day when
they were really just like --
yeah, they're like,
"Just call it 'Wrestling.'"
Yeah, yeah, sure.
"Hockey," yeah.
"Mega Man" was my jam.
-The year.
-Let's call it the year, yeah.
Do you remember that
one Atari game "Adventure"?
-No.
-It's like, you travel around.
I think you were a seahorse.
-What?
-And you had to travel around
and get a key?
-No, really?
-It was rough.
It was real bad.
-You remember "Driver"?
Remember "Driver"?
-"Driver" sounds --
I assume it's car game?
-"Driver," where you just went
around and the cops chased you?
Anybody remember "Driver"?
-Yeah!
-That's a classic.
-That was on...
-Coleco?
-No. Uh...
PlayStation.
-Oh, wow. You're going
really advanced.
Oh, I was saying like,
do you remember "Kaboom"?
-Yeah.
-You didn't like it?
-Nah.
-Because of the explosions?
The violence?
-No, I played like, "Duck Hunt."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Steve Zahn in
"8-Bit Christmas."
Take a look.
-Apparently,
video games have been doing
all kinds of strange things
to children in Japan.
I'm very glad that we do not
have one. [ Laughs ]
-But -- but, you -- you said
I could get one for Christmas.
-I said nothing of the sort.
-Video games make you fat, Jake.
It's a fact.
-Cabbage Patch Kids
don't make you fat.
-No, no, no. No, no.
Dad, you said
I could have one too.
No, I didn't.
Well, okay, I did.
But I thought that it was
an Asian tool brand,
like Makita.
You know what?
No Nintendo in my house.
-I second that.
-Me three,
and that makes a majority.
Looks like a no-go
on the 'tendo.
-Oh!
That's what I'm talking about.
Steve Zahn!
"8-Bit Christmas" premieres
November 24th on HBO Max.